selon l'élysée l'écologie serait je cite
le combat du siècle
c'est en tous les cas ce qui était
indiqué sur son site emmanuel macron a
d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises défendu
son bilan et ses ambitions écologiques
en avançant notamment l'argument du
nécessaire recours au secteur financier
le nerf de la guerre c'est la finance
avec elle pour protéger notre planète
nous pouvons changer la donne c'est du
concret à travers les initiatives que
nous avons engagées continuant
accélérons nous devons le faire pourtant
la finance elle ne semble pas avoir été
particulièrement réceptive à cet appel
du moins si l'on en croit oxfam et
l'association les amis de la terre dans
leur rapport paru ce mardi
ces ong se sont penchés sur les
mouvements de capitaux des quatre plus
grands groupes bancaires français
vous les connaissez tous il s'agit de
bnp paribas du crédit agricole de la
société générale et du groupe bpce qui
détient la banque populaire et la caisse
d'épargné
selon l'étude ces quatre banques
auraient accordé depuis le début de
l'année 2020 100 milliards de dollars de
financements aux entreprises du secteur
des énergies fossiles
c'est à dire le pétrole le charbon et le
gaz des financements qui ont de surcroît
augmenté de plus de 20% entre 2019 et
quant aux bénéficiaires de toute cette
manne là aussi vous les connaissez au
moins en partie il s'agit de bp chevron
exxon mobil repsol et qui n'a encore
total et lee ou encore shell ces huit
géants pétroliers et gaziers ont capté à
eux seuls un quart des financements des
banques dont on vient de parler alors la
cause de cette hausse
et bien selon le rapport les profits des
banques seraient directement liées à la
santé financière du secteur des énergies
fossiles
d'autant que selon une autre enquête 65%
des administrateurs des plus grosses
banques mondiales auraient des
connexions avec l'industrie polluante en
ayant par exemple au cours de leur
carrière occupé des postes dans ce
secteur malgré la percée du business
vert l'économie mondiale et notamment
les banques restent pieds et poings liés
au secteur pétrolier quelles qu'en
soient les raisons ce soutien de la
finance aux pétroliers constituent une
menace écologique tous les indicateurs
climatiques sont au rouge
et il est urgent d'agir massivement 2020
a été l'année la plus chaude depuis
qu'existent les relevés de température
c'est à dire
cent vingt ans et selon le rapport la
stratégie d'investissement des grandes
banques françaises nous conduit tout
droit vers une hausse de quatre degrés à
horizon 2100 soit bien au delà des
accords de paris ainsi emmanuel macron a
certainement conscience de cette
situation
il n'ignore pas non plus que la finance
ne recherche jamais que son propre
intérêt les marchés n'agiront pas par
altruisme en finançant de même la
transition écologique planétaire
c'est aux politiques de les y inciter
voire de les y contraindre
et sur cette question le président de la
république ne s'est pas fait beaucoup
entendre